hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show so in this video i'm going to focus
on
dietary protein restriction in
particular talking about a recent nature
aging publication
lifelong restriction of dietary
branched-chain amino acids has
sex-specific benefits
for frailty and lifespan in mice so to
break this video down i'll begin by
talking about protein restriction
and try and summarize the previous work
that has looked at the implications of
protein restriction
for health span and longevity and then
we'll talk about in particular why in
this study they focus on branch chain
amino acids what they are and
and why they might recapitulate the same
effects of just restricting protein
and then we'll jump into the results of
the study and look in particular
about these sex specific differences and
then lastly i'll give my views and
opinions and what further work i think
should be done
to further explore this topic but
firstly i just want to make a quick
disclaimer that i'm not trying to
suggest protein restriction here
you should consult your doctor before
trying anything the aim of this video is
to take a look at the data to have a bit
of a discussion
and it's not practical advice so firstly
then what is protein restriction
well you probably don't really need me
to explain that so i think the more
interesting question is why would
studies be looking at the implications
of protein restriction
and a lot of this in terms of longevity
research comes from the fact that
calorie restriction has been shown in a
variety of different model organisms
to extend not only lifespan but also
health span and calorie restriction here
is when
food intake is restricted by around 20
to 40 percent
but the interesting thing with these
observations is is it just a generic
reduction in calorie intake
or is it the reduction of specific
dietary macronutrients that's
the result of these improvements in
longevity and health span
now understanding diet is notoriously
complex and a lot of research is still
being conducted to try and
understand what particular components
are mediating the benefits seen in
calorie restriction
and so on from that a lot of research
has already been done to try and
understand
a reduction in protein and its
implication on longevity
one of the reasons for focusing on
protein is due to the fact that amino
acids that make up protein
activates the mammalian target of
rapamycin in its mtol
and activates this signaling pathway
which is notorious for
upregulating growth within a cell and
it's also known in studies that can
inhibit
the activity of this protein complex for
example using rapamycin have also been
shown to extend lifespan immortal
organisms
suggesting that part of the effects of
calorie restriction on improving
longevity
may be mediated through the reduction in
mtor signaling
mediated freedom reduction in protein
and one study that i want to bring up is
this 2014 cell metabolism paper
that emphasized that it's actually the
ratio of these macronutrients
not necessarily just calorie intake that
can dictate the health
benefits seen in calorie restriction and
they summarize their work quite nicely
in this figure here
where you can see that by the different
ratios of protein to carbohydrates
have different impacts for the metabolic
health and lifespan of the rodents
so as you can see in this figure here
low protein is associated with benefits
but these benefits seem to be enhanced
in terms of metabolic health and
lifespan when combined with high
carbohydrates
as opposed to high fats but we also know
from the studies already published that
it's not quite this clear
for example in this 2014 study they
showed that
the benefits of protein reduction may be
age dependent
for example they saw that respondents
aged 50 to 65
reporting a high protein intake had a 75
increase in overall mortality and a
four-fold increase in cancer death risk
during the following 18 years
however high protein intake in
respondents over 65
were associated with reduced cancer and
overall mortality
suggesting that low protein may be more
beneficial for those under 65
than those over 65 and more on from that
well we need protein
we need protein for muscle and it's also
been shown to reduce the risk of
sarcopenia moreover high protein has
commonly been assigned in diets
as it can make you feel more full but
all in all the evidence currently seems
to be swaying towards
low protein diets being healthier and
associated with longer life
and this reminds me of the moment in
down to earth with sac efron
when he was talking with falter longo
and was told that
low protein diets are associated with
longer lifespan
and i honestly really felt for zach at
that point he looked absolutely
terrified
but it is still yet more complex because
it's probably not only protein quantity
but also protein quality that is playing
a role for example there's been studies
that have looked at the differences
between
plant protein and animal protein with
plant protein generally being supported
as being healthier
and more from that as we'll see in this
study
it seems to be that certain amino acids
that make up protein
may be having a bigger role than others
and so there are 20 different
amino acids i once used to know how to
draw all of the structures out by heart
um i have to say i do struggle now with
the aromatic ones
and all of these amino acids vary in
terms of their so-called
r-group which give different amino acids
different biochemical properties
and one way of splitting up amino acids
are into
essential amino acids and non-essential
amino acids
there are nine non-essential amino acids
which means that our bodies can't
produce
these amino acids and that we have to
acquire them through foods
two of these essential amino acids
methionine and tryptophan
have been shown in separate studies to
extend lifespan in rodents
when these respective amino acids were
depleted
now this recent nature aging publication
instead decided to focus on
branched-chain amino acids that include
leucine isoleucine and phthaline
so all three of these are essential
amino acids that we get through diets
and of particular relevance to longevity
is the fact that
leucine is sensed by an inhibitor
of mtor activity and so to be a bit more
specific
leucine is sensed by the protein cestron
2
that would usually inhibit mtor
signaling so when leucine levels are
higher in the cell it binds to saturn 2
and inhibits mtor signaling so this
provided the rationale that potentially
reducing
the level of these branch chain amino
acids of particular relevance leucine
may be able to reduce signaling through
mtor which could subsequently have
beneficial impacts for longevity in
health span and another reason
for investigating this is to find
alternative potentially safer ways to
reducing mtor signaling
than just using rapamycin which is known
to have side effects
so what did they do in this study then
well the first thing that we should
really look at
are the different diets that they used
in the study so they decided to have a
control diet
where 21 of the diet is protein and then
for their low branch chain amino acid
diet
so again that's with leucine isoleucine
and phthaline
they restricted the 21 protein
by two-thirds and lastly they also had
a two-thirds reduction in protein that
produced all of the amino acids
so just a generic protein restricted
diet
and so importantly all of these three
different diets are isocaloric so they
all had the same amount of calories
and they had identical levels of dietary
fat
so what impacts did these different
diets have well firstly they tested
their different diets on a progeria
mouse model now we've briefly met this
model before when i spoke about base
editing and extending lifespan for these
progeria mouse models
and so they have a mutation in the lamin
a gene i won't go into the details
specifically here but effectively these
mice age more rapidly
and so what they found here is that by
giving them this branch chain amino
acids
restricted diets they improved their
lifespan in both males and females
so given this promising style they then
decided to test their reduced branched
chain amino acid diet
on aged mice so here they started the
diet with 16 month old male and female
mice
and in both the males and female mice
they found that those on the branched
chain amino acid reduced diet
weighed less than the controls and they
also were leaner
and they saw this effect even though
both the controls and the restricted
diet were eating the same amount
importantly they also saw in the males
and female mice with the
reduced branched chain amino acid diet
they had a lower blood
glucose level suggesting that these
middle-aged mice were more glucose
tolerant than the control mice
and another striking result was the fact
that the frailty score
which is a way that they can assess
health span of the mice were
significantly lower in the low
branch chain amino acids i'm gonna have
to find a final way of saying that
diet groups and both males and females
i'm gonna say low bcaa as you can see in
these two figures here
anyway despite the frailty index score
remaining lower in the low bcaa
mice the low bcaa diets didn't extend
lifespan in neither males nor females
as you can see here moreover they didn't
see a significant change in the levels
of
igf-1 which is a signaling molecule
upstream of mtor grave signaling
in either the males or females fed the
slow bcaa diet
however another interesting observation
is the fact that
whilst they observed cancer in 68 of the
control fed females
they only observed cancer in 33 percent
of the low bcaa
fed females there wasn't a significant
difference in the males
but this goes back to the understanding
that mtor signaling is
upregulated in cancer obviously due to
the fact that it can upregulate growth
and hence tumorigenesis
so would any of these effects be
enhanced if this low
vca fed diet was given through the
entirety of the mouse lifespan
well yeah by and large the results were
pretty similar
however this time there was no
statistically significant difference
between the control fed and low bcaa-fed
females
in their frailty index whilst in males
there was a significant difference
and correlating with this only in the
male mice
fed the slow bcaa diet did they see that
it significantly increased lifespan with
a 31.8 percent increase in median
lifespan
and quite strikingly one of the low bcaa
fed male mice actually lived to 1456
days
which exceeds the lifespan of the
longest live survivor in several
previous studies
of mice that are fed like ad libertarian
by approximately 25 now to understand
why there seemed to be these sex
dependent differences
they decided to do some transcriptional
profiling so effectively look at what
different genes are being
up or down regulated in these different
diets
in the different mice and quite
strikingly there wasn't really much
overlap between the male and female mice
on this low bcaa diet as you can see
here
i still understanding these differences
in terms of their genes
may be able to help elucidate why they
seem to be more beneficial for the males
than the females
and just a bit more detail in the males
they found that
many of the pathways that were
significantly upregulated
on this diet were centered around
metabolism and
longevity so again that gives us some
molecular underpinning as to how this
diet
is implicating in the improved health
span and lifespan
and you all know i do love a molecular
mechanism
so anyway further delving into this
transcriptional differences
and response to the low bcaa diet would
definitely help us better understand
what this diet is doing and how it's
acting but what else can we take from
this study
well it definitely supports the fact
that these different studies and
interventions
should be done on both genders as there
seems to be
sex-dependent differences and it also
reinforces the importance of diet and
diet to composition which i think we
kind of already knew
but reinforces the fact that it's not
just necessarily protein
quantity but also protein quality that
is playing a role
and in terms of these sex dependent
differences with longevity extension not
being seen in the female mice
it will be important to replicate this
data in different strains of mice with
different genetic backgrounds
more on from that it begs the question
of how translatable is this to humans
would it have the same impact and again
it's just so hard to say at the moment
given the data as clinical trials would
need to be conducted to investigate this
as well as try to better understand how
it may impact
both younger and older patients for
example given the fact that low protein
in over 65s may not be such a good thing
another thing i thought of whilst
making this video was given that i just
spoke about fasting mechanisms
was whether or not their strategy could
be more effective or more less effective
if it was done intermittently and so
it'd be interesting to test that
anyway so maybe in the future we'll be
loosening our leucine levels in our
diets
but we'll just have to wait and see so
with that i hope you've learned
something in this video
and a big thank you to all my patreon
supporters and
as always thanks for listening